[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want to say
whatever we want yeah there we go we got
ed park today
what's up hey how do we know you um
david
used to share an office space with you
guys downtown
um and i was shooting with david then
and i was coming around and
at that time when you guys saw me i was
about 100 pounds every year and you did
the ball handles video with david
no that wasn't me okay you did the night
no i thought you did another one no i
didn't the first one you did was
really well edited i don't know dude was
it one of those nike commercials
sorry that wasn't me you did the kim
jong-il right i did kim jong-un
oh okay most of his not his commercial
spoofs i did a lot of his short skits um
and so i saw you guys around
that space and i was yeah you're like
half the person that i used to know
yeah it's crazy you're like
unrecognizable
yeah i was about 240 some pounds 240
wait are we like the same height yeah
i'm five 240 how much do you weigh now
i'm 145 wow
whoa you're scarier than me it's crazy
wait you lost a hundred pounds you lost
the whole
yeah yeah dude
how did you do it yeah and how long did
it take for like your journey to
to be 100 pounds and it's coke or meth
better
i'll get to that part i think the real
question is
did you feel like your dick got bigger
[ __ ] yeah that's the truth if anyone
needs an excuse to lose weight is that
your dick will get bigger or is it
because you can see it i can see it
and i'm very satisfied with it like
before when you're like kind of insecure
about that and then you lose
weight it's like the easter island heads
they found out they
actually go down deeper
they're pretty cool yeah because if this
is your dick right and like let's say
this is your legs
your dick doesn't look as big but if
your legs were like you're like
[ __ ] my dick's longing on my leg holy
[ __ ]
yeah my friend she's a chubby chaser and
then
my friend she's a chubby chaser and but
she's like the only thing i hate is like
when i
when they sit down and i give a blow
drop i have to lift their head oh
wow that's powerful imagery
like this you're doing a [ __ ] up
block like you're in a cave
wow you haven't even all those lights i
know but uh i think
it really started uh i think i mentioned
it earlier um
i think we were all together to watch
ufc 200
which was like damn you remember the
number yeah i mean because it was 200
right
it was all right right yeah well here's
our i remember
we were at lacey at a dance studio oh
okay i remember
with the dogs running around yeah
constantly oh yeah that fight never came
up
like something happened but we didn't
end up watching we didn't end up
watching
so we pulled up some old ufc fights and
we were watching and
i was standing next to bart and i'm this
fat dude
and i'm like bart if you were fighting
in the ufc which way would you fight it
and you said
like featherweight 145 and then i was
like
no way man you can get to 145 meanwhile
i'm just fat
like 1 4 2 40. yeah and then you gave me
this death look
like in my eye like straight up just
like yes i can
you were like you motivated him i don't
know
you were like how dare you wait was he
fat at that time
no okay so the beginning of the genesis
of this whole
like transformation for you i felt like
oh [ __ ] this guy's going to kick my ass
[Laughter]
what are you doing bart but really i was
probably just staring at the dog running
around
the reality was that it put it actually
gave me a reality check
because i was like how can i not believe
that park can lose weight
when i'm this big and i looked around
just kind of pointed
the finger at myself i looked myself in
the mirror so to say it was just like
i don't even believe i can be that size
when i'm we're like
the same height yeah a little shorter
but i was
way heavier than you full of fat and so
i don't know i just kind of start you
started when you were when you went so
so you were here in l.a yeah and then
you went
back to your hometown to run your family
store right
was it a gas station or something yeah
yeah and then that's when you lost
weight
so what happened there well um i started
learning about fasting about right after
that
oh so right after that you went back to
seattle huh so that was 2015.
i think oh wow and then in 2016 i went
back home
by that time when i was as i was just
learning like fasting and intermittent
fasting
i lost 70 pounds at that point so you
that night you go home and
and that decision is made it's just like
yeah i have to believe
that's crazy i gotta [ __ ] do
something about it like so thank you
bart
it's exciting life coaching fitness
coach here just
the way you motivated me with that with
the asian parent deaths there like
what did you say
[Laughter]
bart says he can do something i really
do believe him yeah
he's like i'm gonna [ __ ] do the next
spacex i'd be like okay bart but i do
believe you but jesus
you know why i think it's because his
natural is probably 145. it could yeah
but this is
like it's built well how much do you
right now uh like 199.
and this is you cutting down already too
right yeah like if he didn't work out is
what i'm saying like he'd probably
stay a skinny dude yeah like in high
school it's like 120 ish 110ish so
that's why it was believable
because people that meet him afterwards
is like yo
dude no way yeah i think the last time i
was this weight was in sixth grade
[Laughter]
so when when did you become overweight
uh probably around
fifth grade and on i would just slowly
just gain weight and then
summertime comes you fluctuate you lose
weight and you gain weight lose weight
gain and then just
over decades it just i just got really
big and then it kind of becomes a part
of my identity too i feel like
you're like oh i'm just the big guy and
then just like want to eat and
i mean i never thought i was ugly
that's good yeah i was still pretty
happy with myself um
mostly i think that was the relationship
me and david had it was like two fat
guys that are confident in ourselves
that's the type yeah you guys are very
jolly
jolly chubby dudes did you feel like you
left them behind he was like
we're supposed to be fat together dude
what the hell
well so i moved back home um
and you know how it is like you you move
home and you kind of get this
weird travel depression or something i
gained back like 25 pounds
when you went back to washington so you
lost some weight in l.a
yeah go to washington gained it back
gained it back and then i was like here
we go again that cycle of fluctuation oh
i lose weight and then my food is so
damn tasty exactly so i was at
a afc championship game at my friend's
house and just ate a bunch of food
and i just remember like i could feel my
skin splitting
what like you feel like the fat growing
feel like my
my like i feel the skin stretching on my
body
you mean like you ate so much that it
expanded yeah like i have stretch marks
everywhere
you know that's buffalo wild wings man
literally that falling monday was just
like i'm not gonna eat
i'm not gonna eat today and then the
next day i was like well how long did
you give yourself to like fast like
what was your fasting technique usually
before it was just
don't eat after 8 pm and that was it
yeah and then just that alone helped me
lose
[ __ ] really yeah to change what you were
eating well that's the part i get to
after that monday i don't eat i wake up
tuesday
i don't feel like eating i'm not gonna
eat it again what the hell how big were
you at this point
i was about 2 20. okay yeah because
on fasting i've heard that bigger
people have energy like the fat there's
a lot of reserves
yeah so they go there there's a guy that
went 30 days without right i think he
could die
he had the record there's a documentary
on a guy who did it for 59 days yeah
the world record is like 400 days for
this guy who was like 400 pounds yeah
you have the mind of steel dude
i can't i can't even barely skip one
meal i thought you were the type to have
this kind of mindset
when it comes to food he's hangry if i
if i went to jail i'll be the kind of
guy that stuffs food in my ass so i
could eat it later
well i'll tell you like by wednesday i
was feeling like [ __ ]
now like the energy was leaving me third
day right everyone says third day yeah
the third day was hurting but then i
don't know why
like i was like i'm not gonna eat today
either i wasn't i wasn't planning on not
eating for this long but
i felt like i knew this there's so much
fat in me this is all energy
yeah yeah it's all supposed to burn i
didn't actually look it up i just kind
of had this
one plus one mindset i mean thank god
you're right because i was always afraid
to not eat for a day because i thought i
was going to die same i thought not
eating for
a day is like a cruel starvation
kind of thing but like so many religions
do it
like during ramadan and all that they'd
intermittent fast so as i was
uh fasting these during this time i'm
like running my store and going back and
forth and i'm just drinking a [ __ ] ton
of smart water
and in the meantime too i'm googling
like
benefits of fasting and i'm finding out
all this great information
so i'm like i'll do it one more day uh
and on
the fifth day i finally decided okay
well how do i break this fast
right i haven't been eating my kfc is
the only way
i mean i didn't want to get sick or hurt
and whatever right
but i feel you eat kfc after a five-day
fashion
you might diarrhea yeah it's like what's
the point
you'll turn into fried chicken exactly
it just comes out the exact same way
there's no
stomach acid yeah that's [ __ ] by the
way don't quote me on that
but hey guys today's video is brought to
you by audible
and on audible you can find all kinds of
audiobooks
and that really helps me because i live
30 minutes away from the jk office
and 40 minutes away from the gym pretty
much so when i'm driving
i'm like bored of all the music that i
hear on the radio all the time so
recently i've been listening to
audiobook
called how to win friends and influence
people i'm on that one right now
man i really like it because it's the
the title is kind of misleading because
i think they
wrote it in the 50s or something so it's
not like how to like
control you but it's more about like how
to understand what motivates people so
you can kind of be a better communicator
and better leader
and you know like since i do i'm like a
leader in two companies
i want to be able to talk to people
better and how to like help people
motivate people and like how to
um pretty much like be able to
communicate my thoughts without
hurting people's feelings and know where
people are coming from so i've been
really liking this book
because it pretty much i've timed it
where if i do
like four trips that's a chapter based
on my commute
yeah i can almost kind of like calculate
when i'm gonna finish each book that i
read
and i like to do it while i'm driving
too because i feel productive while i'm
on the road and then
when i get out of the car it's still
fresh in my mind
and i can practice whatever i learned
but what's cool is that
audible doesn't only have books and
audiobooks on there there's like
podcasts there's comedy they have like
audible originals
they just have super amounts of content
so it's super awesome
go check it out visit audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500
that's audible.com off the record or go
ahead and text
off the record to 500-500
as i was googling it i found out that uh
keto
and fasting go hand-in-hand oh yeah yeah
yeah so what's keto again
fat 70 fat macros oh really
yeah so i broke my fast with cheese and
i started
uh i had like uh i read about coconut
oils like scoop of that yeah
peanut butter no there's sugar in there
right sugar
after that i was like on a mission to
never have sugar again
yeah dude isn't it crazy
i cut sugar out for a month and it's the
why cut sugar and coffee at the same
time yikes how much did that hurt
i felt like i was on a period but then
after the third or fourth day
you know what that feels like for sure
he would he's done research actually yep
he's probably undecisive you know feel
like
yeah stomach cramps he changed his mind
a lot yeah
started complaining yeah oh so you've
always been on your period
very nice very nice
so when you ate the cheese did it feel
like um
like this is the energy your body needed
to feel like food coma ish should it
feel heavy or
like so these days that when i break
extended fasts
like um and i have mct oil or coconut
oil just like a tablespoon
and then i have some pork belly which is
like great
fat protein keto ratio right
yeah and i feel like this
[ __ ] turning like energy going
through my veins into my
brain like through my heart and like i
feel like
like i can do anything like ron jeremy
yeah
just phil roger
the craziest part of fasting that i
experienced
was the uh calmness and the mood
i was mind blown and i was like start
understanding monks
and all these religious people and i
feel like food
is probably the leading factor of stress
anxiety panic attacks and so many other
things
because i was like what the [ __ ] i feel
like a baby that's being cradled right
now i'm so like
floaty for me what i learned it was
actually my sugar addiction
like sugar is a narcotic that's what i
mean um because
yeah it's a legal drug it is but it's so
good it's
it's delicious right and but look at the
long-term effects
on people look at what happens to you if
you don't have sugar for a day
like you feel and that's that's what i
was telling people about what hangryness
is
because i don't get angry no more and i
used to right but it's that
sudden because you have the dependency
to glucose right so that's
so your body's like i need i need
glucose to [ __ ] energy
and then it like it depletes and it's
not used to getting into ketosis which
is burning the fat
so it's like i need energy go eat now
yeah and that's crazy that's when
similar to people on drugs going through
with traumatic anxiety
we're withdrawing every day that's what
angry is it's sugar withdrawals
do you uh eat fruits at all or not nope
i don't even eat onions
there's too much sugar and onions really
cut out sugar that hardcore yeah like
wow sugar that's i was like
i can't this is the way i have i love
cooking so what's your what's your diet
now so it's like pork belly obviously
pork belly kimchi how do you prepare
your pork belly
i sous-vide it every day i take the time
i
[ __ ] like do the vacuum seal give it
four hours
you must be really good at making pork
belly yeah i'm pretty good at it
you have a sous-vide machine yeah that's
just the bucket and then
what's the longest you've done because i
just did a 48 hour
this weekend for fasting from sunday 9
p.m
to tuesday night then how did you break
it what did you eat
with beef broth yeah and then
like i drank beef broth 30 minutes later
i made a lean steak
like a four ounce lean steak i went to
sleep so i was in keto till the next day
and i didn't eat till 3 p.m next day and
then i
broke it again with beef broth and then
i went and got some like noodles and all
kinds of other stuff and it was fine
you know it was crazy i'm hearing all
this and i'm like i think i've been
fasting my whole life
but i well not anymore not like in the
last like two years or whatever i eat
normal now
but my whole life though i would not eat
like i'll eat one meal
in like 48 hours sometimes wow or less
than that you don't even snack in
between
no like nothing i was just [ __ ] you
weren't dying right no but that's the
thing like i was
i was feeling like [ __ ] i was hangry i
was the sugar because yeah i wasn't
i wasn't careful with what i was putting
back into my body
because i wasn't doing this on purpose i
just didn't like eating period like it
was just
the act of eating was not enjoyable for
me when i first did intermittent fasting
i actually got hypoglycemia
because i didn't do it right it's
hypoglycemia it's um
it's it's like uh what do you call it
low blood sugar
do you feel like tired and fatigued get
like an anxiety attack
from no eating i forgot yeah it feels
like that though
it feels like your body's stressed the
[ __ ] out like you're running away from
an animal
and it's like an adrenaline rush and
then you feel like
really weird yeah but anyways um i got
scared to do it again and then i tried
it again but i
this time i found out that like what
you're supposed to do
is cut out caffeine and sugar before you
go
on to intermittent fasting so i went
paleo
or most tried and then i did a 16 hour
from 9 p.m to 1 p.m i wouldn't eat
pushed it to 3 to 3 p.m and then i said
all right here we go i'm not going to
eat tomorrow
40th hour was freaking hard for me yeah
i think though when you give yourself a
time
though uh i think uh it
takes you in a mentality of of actually
like this will be over soon you will eat
soon or whatever
yeah i think that's why i'm hearing the
common through line for this for you
anyway
is that you have like this mental
like discipline through this almost like
doing this has given you this energy and
this mental discipline
above all things i think i had to fall
out of love with food for one
and so just look at it as energy
impossible yeah wow
i got stockholm syndrome with food i
have the ability to eat the same [ __ ]
every day
i don't know what that feels like so i
eat pork belly
and kimchi every [ __ ] day for every
meal what the [ __ ] apparently happens
well
every single meal every day you don't
even change it up with
eggs or cheese or like okay well
obviously cheese snacks
pork skin uh so you're always in ketosis
you don't
really no vegetables nothing yeah uh
well i'll
i'll have vegetables like dark leafy
greens but no like potatoes and no
potatoes wow
starch all this like before covid what
would you do when you wanted to go out
with friends and go eat
i would go out and watch my friends eat
and i joined the conversation
man you got a lot of discipline dude i
had to you you stopped though like um
cam was over eating chicken and i was on
my fast it was day two and i was just
watching them and then
you just get over it yeah it's crazy you
you
don't have a desire yeah you stop
craving especially if you
have the thought like you're not going
to die in fact you will eat again soon
but the cool thing is this unexplainable
calm clear clarity like the first day i
i couldn't think i was
like kind of groggy and then the next
day i woke up at like six in the morning
with hella energy
and i was like what the [ __ ] so i
believe that
is when you're getting into ketosis and
also
like as when you're fasting i guess 12
hours into fasting and that's called an
anaerobic fast
but 16 hours into fasting that's called
like a ketogenic fast
that in 16 hours you'll burn all your
glycogen storage
which is equal to one hour of high
intensity are you using strips because
that's what i did to figure out if i was
on ketosis or not i
dripped it like piano to see if you have
ketones in your pee
through the pee they can tell if you're
burning the fat or
science when i started um it works right
because
uh my body was producing a [ __ ] ton of
ketones but over like
maybe 90 days when i was doing it past
three months p-strips don't work anymore
because your body will you
fasted for three months well the like
this diet and
fasting life oh you mean intermittent
fasting oh okay okay your body will
regulate the amount of ketones it needs
yeah yeah
so p-strips work because your body's
just peeing out the rest of the ketones
you don't need
that you produced right and then over
time it'll just regulate as much
ketones as you need so what's happening
when you're feeling that enlightenment
um autophagy is happening as well
because you're not actually eating
anything so your body starts going
towards your body fat but your
cells your healthy cells will start
recycling and cannibalizing your weak
cells that's where the immune system go
up
goes up and now are you covered proof i
don't know but i
haven't had anything [ __ ] um let's see
the next part was that um
hgh your natural hgh levels rise so if
you do a three day fast you
you will like produce
350 the normal amount of hgh
if you fast for seven days it'll go up a
thousand two hundred fifty percent
oh yeah so apparently bodybuilders are
now going into fasting because autophagy
also prevents
muscle um what's it called when your
muscle shrink
atrophy yeah wait so then the key thing
here
for this to work is the whole like
eliminating sugar
eliminating sugar and um making sure
that you're hitting 16 hours a day and
no i'm not out there fasting three days
every week i don't
do that i hate ketosis around 20. i i
kept
experimenting for about two weeks and
for me ketosis
hits around 20th hour well i've been
doing this diet for like
three years now so i think i can hit
ketosis like a general good amount of
produce a good amount of ketones within
three days
so the like i said p-strips don't work
but i get this thing called
keto rash on my chest so
when i start seeing like these red bumps
that's how i know i'm in ketosis
wow so it happens in two percent of
people on this earth
most of them being asian women and then
i also get it too
[Laughter]
asian women and
[Laughter]
very quickly did you have any setbacks
to all this stuff oh yeah um
obviously the sugar withdrawals like um
the
when you the irritability all these
things i would suggest like
you have to talk to your doctor first
before like don't turn it into an eating
disorder guys
but you know all the all the things that
i've read though
is that people recommend cutting getting
rid of the addiction of caffeine and
sugar
first get that out of the way before you
do it because you're gonna have
a hell of a harder time just going cold
turkey into the fast
and i took that and i cut it for at
least two weeks
and i had a great time like it was it
was an adventure i had a great
relationship i'm gonna do it again
so for you you you were talking to your
doctor through this whole thing no
i just did my thing by googling [ __ ] and
making sure
this was reputable sources that this
science was
was real and this was coming out of it
and the guy who discovered autophagy
he won a nobel peace prize for it right
and look at what it's done for me
it's not like crock pot kind of science
[ __ ] it's it's legit
this is your body doing amazing things
for you yeah well crock pots are pretty
valuable i like them i use them use crop
pots to render my fat
and i save my pork he thinks that's all
[Music]
[ __ ]
you